this video is made possible by nordvpn
we live our lives online more and more
these days particularly over the last
year and unfortunately that means that
cybercrime is also on the rise that's
where nordvpn comes in with nordvpn all
your internet data stays safe behind a
wall of next generation encryption and
that's the kind of safety that we should
all be thinking about
as we've seen in just the last year in
hong kong myanmar and belarus political
situations can change rapidly bringing
censorship restrictions and intrusive
government controls well nordvpn
provides a kind of invisibility blanket
you can mask your ip address so that
others can't see what you are browsing
online remember that nordvpn has servers
all over the globe meaning that you can
enjoy instant secure access to hundreds
of streaming websites worldwide and one
account lets you connect up to six
devices which means that you get to
watch visualpolitik content from
anywhere on the planet and right now you
can get a huge discount on a two-year
plan of nordvpn at nordvpn.com
visualpolitik and you'll get an
additional four months for free it's
risk-free with nord's 30-day money-back
guarantee and now it's grant's turn
[Music]
have you ever thought about what would
happen if your country literally started
to become extinct that is if its
population were to decline people were
to grow older the labor force would
become scarce and many schools towns and
neighborhoods were to gradually become
empty well this is more or less the
process that is already being
experienced in japan the country with
the oldest population in the world check
this out
[Music]
today one in four japanese citizens is
over 65 years old they represent 28.7 of
the entire japanese population as a
comparison in the european union another
territory with many problems with
demographic aging this percentage barely
exceeds 20 in other words if all
japanese people over the age of 65
formed their own country that country
would have roughly the population of
poland or canada in addition japan is
the country with the most centaurians in
the world approximately 80 000 japanese
have crossed a 100-year barrier
and indeed for many experts the process
underway in japan is just a taste of
what's to come in much of the developed
world in just a few decades precisely
for this reason japan may become a
testing ground for how to deal with the
challenges posed by the reversal of the
demographic pyramid and take note
because this is not just an amusing
anomaly this issue could jeopardize the
entire economic and social model of all
of our countries and this is where a few
questions arise exactly what challenges
are we talking about how can we prevent
our countries and societies from
languishing in the face of an
increasingly aging population what is
japan's experience of this so far well
in this video we will try to answer
these and other questions but first let
me thank once again all of the people
who generously support us on patreon
from the most modest contribution to the
super patrons thanks to you this project
can aspire to improve every day your
commitment and your help contribute to
make visualpolitik one of the leading
independent political channels on
youtube so really from the whole team
once again thank you all so much now
that said let's get cracking
an explosive combination
[Music]
those of you who have watched a few
videos will know that usually we are not
very fond of bombarding you with data
but on this occasion in order to
understand what is really happening in
japan there are some numbers that we
simply must take into account we are
talking about a country with the worst
possible projections in terms of aging
to give you an idea by 2036 it is
estimated that those over 65 years of
age will already account for almost 35
of the entire population at the same
time the fertility rate which began to
fall in the 1970s is moving further and
further away from the demographic
replacement rate of 2.1 children per
woman well in japan today this figure
barely exceeds 1.4 children per woman
one of the lowest rates in the world
although it must be noted the south
koreans take the lead in this matter
check this out
and of course the explosive cocktail of
more and more elderly people and fewer
and fewer children leads irredeemably to
one thing the movie children of men now
i'm kidding population contraction is
what it actually leads to
[Music]
in fact since 2011 the japanese
population has not stopped shrinking in
2020 alone japan's population declined
by almost 400 000 people during that
year 38 of the country's 47 prefectures
lost population in fact japan's
population is expected to go from around
126 million in 2020 to around 111
million by 2040. and are you ready for
this one to just over 87 million by
2065. in a little more than 40 years
japan will lose more than 30 of its
inhabitants we are talking about an
unprecedented demographic contraction
japan drops out of the 10 most populous
countries 2020 census as you can imagine
these kind of demographic changes have
significant implications for all areas
of the country including of course the
economy
working age population projected to
shrink in japan and south korea an oecd
report has calculated that by 2050
japan's working age population would
have declined to 61.8 percent compared
to the population in 2000. at this point
i'm sure most of you are wondering
alright grant but what are the causes
behind all this negative data how much
is the responsibility of society and how
much is the responsibility of public
policy well let's take a look at that
now
[Music]
a country that is becoming extinct
there are only a few countries in the
world that are already experiencing
demographic decline south korea and
japan are currently two of the most
prominent cases but why what factors are
contributing to this scenario we're
going to focus on the case of japan but
the situation in south korea is very
very similar the point is that we will
be able to find causes and factors
linked to the social and cultural aspect
on the one hand and to the economic
political aspect on the other let's
start by taking a look at the first
factors firstly the japanese labor
market is probably one of the most
anti-family friendly markets in the
world the japanese have to deal with
extremely long working hours that often
leave little room to even consider
starting a family
what's more in the case of japan
requesting medical leave or parental
leave is frowned upon and can have
professional consequences let's just say
that despite the fact that japanese law
recognizes 36 weeks of paid maternity
leave and the country leads the world in
paternity rights with 30 weeks cultural
barriers still way very heavily for
example to give you an idea despite the
provisions of the law men who apply for
paid paternity leave are still in the
minority and usually barely reach two
weeks of leave far less than what is
legally recognized
[Music]
another social factor affecting birth
rates is the increasing tendency of the
japanese not to form couples according
to the latest available data more than
35 of the population in japan lives
alone and what is more surprising many
japanese people do not even bother to
have a partner so if you want a fling
it's not really clear whether going to
japan is a great idea or a lousy one i'm
sorry for all the anime heads out there
[Music]
then the numbers also tell us that
whether for cultural or economic reasons
the japanese are also having a lot of
trouble adopting to the changing job
market you see the japanese labour
market has traditionally been
characterized by stable jobs the general
world view was that if a worker worked
hard enough he could stay in the same
company all his life progressively
improving his working conditions of
course such jobs known in the country as
regular jobs have been in sharp decline
everywhere since the 1990s for example
between 1995 and 2008 alone the number
of regular workers fell by 3.8 million
while temporary and freelance positions
grew by 7.6 million and what did the
demographics tell us well only 30 of
temporary workers or freelancers in
their 30s are married that's almost half
as many as regular workers of the same
age so in this case as you can see
precariousness or perceived lack of
employment security could be having an
important influence because obviously
the more singles the fewer children now
many of you may be wondering alright
alright grant but if there's a lack of
children and a lack of workers why not
encourage immigration
[Music]
and this is actually a very relevant
issue in a developed country the arrival
of immigrants has not only made it
possible to maintain or expand the labor
force but has also helped to raise birth
rates however japan is perhaps one of
the most restrictive countries in the
world in this respect as of june 2019
only two percent of japan's population
were foreign residents we are talking
about just over 2.8 million people by
comparison spain a country with a
population three times smaller has
almost twice as many immigrants five and
a half million which is 11.4 of the
population
[Music]
clearly this has mostly political
explanations until 2018 japanese
immigration law only granted legal
residents with a right to work to highly
qualified professionals professionals in
training programs from developing
countries and students under certain
conditions in practice visas were the
property of the company and were linked
directly to the employment contract in
other words if the company had finished
with you you had to leave the country it
was as simple as that since 2018 though
and as we have already mentioned in
previous videos more flexibility has
been introduced for example two types of
labour immigrant categories have been
created the first allows lower skilled
foreign workers in specific sectors to
stay in the country for five years
however they are not allowed to bring
their families to the country the second
category allows foreigners with more
advanced training to bring their family
to japan and live indefinitely
converting their visa into a permanent
visa under certain criteria
in short emigrating to japan is a trial
despite the fact that they need people
like a desert needs rain and i'm not
overstating it by saying that the
depopulation that japan is beginning to
experience is already having noticeable
consequences and has only just begun do
you want to know more about the problems
that the demographic challenge is
already causing in the land of the
rising sun of course you do so listen up
[Music]
the looming catastrophe
let me throw a question at you did you
know that in japan there are no fewer
than 896 cities and towns facing
complete extinction by the year 2040.
and this is no journalistic exaggeration
there are in fact official forecasts
made by the national institute of
population and social security research
affiliated with japan's ministry of
health labor and welfare and that's not
all the percentage of vacant housing
because there are no longer people
interested in occupying them i mean now
accounts for 13.5 of all housing in
japan about eight and a half million
residencies another fact between the
year 2002 and 2017 more than 7000 public
schools in japan were closed due to a
lack of children obviously all these
problems are concentrated mainly in the
rural areas farthest from the main
cities where the population continues to
squeeze into tiny apartments little
bigger than a shoebox at exorbitant
prices something very different to what
is already happening outside the major
metropolises
the agricultural population can be a
good illustration of this in 2015 the
1.75 million people engaged in
agriculture no less than 63.5 percent
were over 65 years old a percentage that
had tripled in three decades
this makes japan the country with the
tightest ratio of dependence to people
of working age in the oecd and by 2060
the ratio was expected to reach one
elderly person for every person of
working age you can imagine what this
means in terms of social costs however
at least the japanese pension system is
mixed it combines a public welfare
pension with individual private savings
plans this means that the maximum public
pension that a japanese person can
receive when retiring at the age of 65
after contributing 40 years to the
national pension plan is only 7500 or
6400 euros per year which is equivalent
to just over 628 or 530 euros per month
in spain for example where demographic
problems are not very different and the
pension system is pay as you go the
maximum pension exceeds 43 000 or 37 000
euros per year almost six times the
maximum pension in japan you can already
imagine here the scenario that is
brewing in spain and with it the whole
eurozone we talked in detail about this
issue in a past video i'll link for you
in the description but let's not get
sidetracked
generally there is some consensus that a
sharp drop in population will also lead
to fewer workers and thus lower output
although with heavy investment in
capital goods such as machinery and
robotics this could be mitigated at
least that is the hope of japanese
economists nevertheless long-term
economic simulations in some studies
indicate that japan's demographic
debacle will cause national gdp to fall
by 20 over the next century in absolute
terms and by around five percent in per
capita terms
and then there is the question of public
spending for example in 2018 japan's
healthcare spending reached 10.9 of gdp
and by 2030 is expected to account for
12.1 percent this is because healthcare
spending is closely related to the age
of patients in japan per capita
healthcare spending for those under 75
average 2134.
in 2018. for those over 75 the figure
soared to nine thousand dollars that's
four times more in short this is the
demographic scenario facing japan a
country that in just one generation will
lose almost a third of its population
and we'll have to deal with a downward
gdp evolution and higher social expenses
regarding the changes they are making to
adapt to this situation we covered this
in detail in a past video here on
visualpolitik and i'll link that one in
the description too the question now is
what is the solution to a demographic
collapse will japan end up becoming one
of the countries most receptive to
immigration due to the severe crisis
that is knocking on their door and will
this give hope to the weebs you can
leave your opinions here below in the
comments and remember if you liked this
video don't forget to like and subscribe
to our channel once again thank you for
being there all the best and i'll see
you next time
[Music]
you